if you guys are gonna move japan i wanna
i wanna be honest with you and tell you
what's gonna be fun and what's gonna say
yeah there's gonna be there's gonna be
lots of [ __ ] great things about it
but just be prepared for those little
inconveniences
whenever you have to do anything to do
with like japanese bureaucracy or just
setting
setting up your living situation yeah i
i you will be writing your name address
and phone number
more times than you'll ever think you
all lose at least a week
just yeah i think i think that's the
thing that annoys me in the uk when i
had to deal with this stuff it was
it was maybe an hour out of my day at
most and i get on my day
if it happens here it derails your whole
week yeah like it takes it completely
you have to reschedule everything cancel
everything you're doing because
you've got a call from the bank they
said that your card's cancelled and they
didn't tell you
i just remembered like i don't know if
you guys have in the uk but like
in japanese and australian airports
there's like sometimes that service
where like you know how
on your suitcase you can pull like a
belt so it doesn't burst open
some people forget that or you know
don't buy that so instead you can like
you can use a service that you can like
wrap up your bag and like i said
okay yeah yeah in australia it's like 10
seconds you're just like
wrap this up here's the money they do it
all right see you later
i did it in hanada once in japan and
they were like okay can you fill out
this form
uh write your name address and phone
number i'm like
i'm never gonna see you again just wrap
up my god damn bad
get the [ __ ] cling film out wrap it
around and i'll give you 20 bucks
i looked at this woman i was like what
do you need this for like why do you
need to know my name phone number and
address and they're like oh you know
like just in case i'm like
i guess you're wrapping my bag in
plastic i'm a customer
i i will do it myself me the give me the
give me the clean round
i'll [ __ ] blow myself right now i
will pay you
to not fill it that way it was
ridiculous it's frustrating man and i
just wasted like you know two minutes of
my life filling out this form that
for one i don't even know what they're
gonna use it for but second of all
completely unnecessary
frustrating giving out your whole
[ __ ] information to
[ __ ] that you feel like it just totally
doesn't need it right yeah like i just
don't want to deal with that i hate
doing that but it's also like you know i
feel as well like
there's so many situations where you're
canceling something or you know you're
upgrading something right and you're
just like all right can you write your
phone number and address i'm like
i'm pretty sure all my information is
his own system just look it up
i'll give you my [ __ ] name check it
out i'll let you know yeah i'll keep you
like how often do you think i'm changing
my name and address
like one one thing i'm [ __ ] dreading
when we move because
we're all planning to move from where we
are now i mean you're already in the
process of moving
yeah um is just the process of changing
my address
in every bill that i've had and
i'm just i i wake up in a cold sweat at
night sometimes being like
i got to do that i haven't been
suffering for the past month on that
and it shouldn't be a suffering it just
sucks because i feel like just life just
comes to a halt for a month because
they've designed systems that
make it so yeah like and it's got
nothing to do with like you know
people who don't understand the language
having a hard time no
even if you're fully japanese it's still
hard as [ __ ] to do and it shouldn't be
that hard
like you get pretty good customer
service in most aspects of
japanese life i think but this for some
reason with uh
personal information companies i feel
like it comes to a whole and it doesn't
it doesn't improve at all like the
customer service isn't any better for it
uh i think that's why i think japan has
one of the lowest productivities
out of yeah of first world countries i'm
not surprised uh
because they work the most we would have
flying cars by now
they work more hours than any other
country and have less to show for it
yeah you know what i mean like
you know i think in some european
countries they're considering a four-day
work week even
and you know which is like that's
fantastic you you bring that up to
government officials in japan they're
like
how does that how does that country run
how is that not a third how is it a
third world country
how is their economy not crippling to
the ground because again it's just like
how do you fix it when everything in
society has been made to be
long-winded bloated and slow like what
do you do
like how do you fix that because it's
like a whole cultural thing this is a
country where
a lot of schools are still six days a
week yeah
i mean it's ridiculous little and four
day work week what yeah i mean it took
like a [ __ ] global pandemic right for
the country to embrace working from home
and online meetings
right they were like they were throwing
out like the buzzword of like
home workstation or whatever the [ __ ] it
was like like it was a new thing that
was just invented
like we've come up with this
revolutionary thing get this
you can work from home and japanese
people are like impossible
that is that's again
they call it telework like also i think
i think they're now
slowly starting to face out the hanko
because of it they're they're finally
putting in like the government they're
bringing it up and trying to explain
huncles i don't think we have
hunk hunker basically is like the it's
like a stamp essentially that has your
surname on it or you know company name
or whatever basically
it's the japanese equivalent of a
signature but
incredibly tedious it's incredibly
tedious because that means you have to
carry your hanko
everywhere yeah whenever you're like if
if you forget
you're hungry if i've had moments where
i'm like i have everything
except the hunk and they just don't
accept it yeah and i'm just like
this is a stamp i bought a donkey hotel
for like 200 years
like the dollar shop here yeah you can
you can just get it at a dollar imagine
your name is connor right
and then you know you you got those gift
shops and they have like the license
plates like connor yeah
it's like that like imagine you just go
to the store you find your name on the
license plate and then you bring it and
go look it's my name
and it's my name look take a picture the
thing is is like i i've read up a thing
as to why
japan still uses the hanko and not
signatures and
the most accepted like excuse i guess
i'm going to just go on course
as why they don't use signatures they
were like well anyone can
copy a signature anyone can go to donkey
hot air
and buy a two dollar stamp what are you
on it's yeah it's so dumb
yeah i mean if you have a popular name
yeah like
yeah what happens if you have a popular
name yeah right what is it uh what is it
what's the one you always see tanaka is
that the one yeah like subtle like any
of like
probably has the same [ __ ] don
quixote stamp yeah yeah so i'm like
there's [ __ ] like it's signature is
way harder to copy than buying a stamp
like did you hear about the [ __ ] josh
battle royale that happened recently
did you hear about this okay
so like i i think like a year ago some
guy
in like some state or something he
looked up
every he was his name josh josh wayne
josh wayne josh
wayne just wayne he looked up like every
josh on facebook in his area
and added them to a group right and he
just sends a message
guys you know why we're here we're going
to battle for the name josh
they're are only josh's here we are
going to have a battle royale
and whoever's whoever emerges victorious
can keep the name josh
so that's how it works with hankers
there's literally
i feel like they have to do that with
hank it's literally a [ __ ] battle
royale movie in japan
where it's that exact same concept is it
really yeah yeah it's called
it's called real tag where basically
it's it's like a survival horror movie
it's actually a really good movie and
book
but basically in this it's set in like
the future where the king of japan his
name is sato which is the most
common surname in japan and he's like i
want to be the only subtle
so what he does is every night at
midnight he's like all of the subtles in
the country have you come out legend
game yeah
literally and they're like and they're
like to all satos of japan
there are too many of you so we're gonna
get rid of some of you and it's like
literally a survival horror movie where
all the sato is like
running for their life not to get
[ __ ] illuminated
it's a great [ __ ] movie yeah it's
like an anime yeah it really does
it's not a great movie but it's
literally like